وبنشان التعبئه قال بوتين ان 250 الف جندي
ممن خضعوا للتعبئه الجزئيه يعتبرون
احتياطا كافيا للحرب في اوكرانيا
وقال وزير الدفاع روسيه
يعملون في منطقه العمليات العسكريه
باوكرانيا واضاف شوكو خلال اجتماع اجتماع
الرئيس بوتين مع قاده وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان اكثر من 500 قمر
لصالح القوات الاوكرانيه بما فيها 70 قمرا
عسكريا واشر شويجو الى ان المستوى استعداد
ما سماه ثلوث النووي الروسيه يضمن تحقيق
توازن الاستراتيجيه لافتا الا ان نشر
منظومه سرمات الصاروخيه البالستيه عابره
للقارات
واقترح الوزير الروسي اجراءات بتوسيع
القوات الروسيه والقواعد العسكريه نظرا
لتوسع نيته شارع شيكو الى ان عمليه
التعبئه الجزئيه في روسيا شاهدت صعوبات
قائلا انه سيتم تسريعه امداد القوات روسيا
في اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه المطلوبه